the moon has been our friendly neighbor
in the sky for billions of years it's
guided us home kept us on time protected
us propelled us into space and has even
lunched dance crazes it's hard to fathom
what we would do without it but for the
sake of science let's try to envision a
moonless world what would happen to
earth would humans still exist and what
would life be like this is what if and
here's what would happen if the moon had
never formed so how exactly did we get a
moon in the first place
scientists believe it started off with a
splash the giant impact hypothesis also
known as the big splash theorizes that a
mars-sized celestial object named Theia
came crashing into Earth four and a half
billion years ago tossing vaporized
particles of Earth's crust into space at
this point Earth was still a baby only
30 to 50 million years old and not much
more than molten lava some scientists
call this early Earth Gaia
over time the debris of Gaia and the
Theia joined together in a dance with
Earth's gravity and formed the moon we
know and love today and lucky for us our
moon's orbit and gravitational pull tilt
the earth 23.4 degrees
creating tide
that helps slow the rotation of our
planet just enough for life to safely
exist or so we think
despite a popular theory having a moon
is no longer a requirement for life to
exist so could we really exist without
our Moon how would we survive well with
a little gravitational help from our
friends the Sun and Jupiter life could
still have evolved without a moon but
how well with no moon to keep the earth
on an even keel things might get a
little wobbly we'd have to put up with
some extreme weather our concept of time
and seasons would drastically change and
we may evolve to look short and stubby
you can learn more about this in our
other video what if we lost the moon
there is however another hypothesis in a
study conducted at the NASA Ames
Research Center in 2011 scientists
performed complex simulations in which
the earth didn't have its moon and
measured the effects on Earth's spin
over time the results were shocking they
discovered that the Earth's wobble would
eventually stabilize due to Jupiter's
immense gravitational pull deviating no
more than 10 degrees off its access
thanks Jupiter scientists have also
found that the earth might have spun
backward before the mean formed this
would mean that the Sun would rise in
the West and set in the east feeling
dizzy yet our sky would be a lot darker
than usual without the moon to reflect
the light of the Sun but that would be
perfect for stargazing my G we'd still
have a little bit of light from Venus to
help light our way in the dark but the
moon is 2,000 times brighter
at the very least we wouldn't have to
put up with wolves keeping us awake at
night
farmers would have to be careful with
their crops without a harvest moon and
women's menstrual cycles would change
despite these conditions there's a lot
more to our Moon than just pure science
without it our whole idea of the
universe could change dramatically
slowing our progress as a species if it
worked for Italian astronomer Galileo
discovery of the moon's spherical shape
in 1609 we'd probably still think the
earth was the center of the universe
houston we have a problem
an idea proposed by Aristotle in 284 BCE
that was widely accepted for over 1500
years our Moon was instrumental in
launching a space race which propelled
humans to the stars in the words of Neil
Armstrong going to the moon was apart
one giant leap for mankind without it
who knows if we'd even bother traveling
to space and would there be any chance
of us ever becoming space tourists well
that's a story for another what if
[Music]